This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. January of 2020 marked the New York Public Library's 125th anniversary. And to celebrate, they published a list of the 10 most checked out books in the history of the library. And there's one thing about the list that you really can't help but notice right away. That's our producer Joe Rosenberg. It's made up almost entirely of children's books.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2020年1月是纽约公共图书馆成立125周年。为了庆祝，他们发布了一份图书馆历史上借阅次数最多的10本书的名单。关于这份名单，有一点你真的会立刻注意到。那是我们的制作人乔·罗森伯格。它几乎完全由儿童读物组成。
So the snowy day, the cat in the hat, where the wild things are, Charlotte's web. Dan Coise is a writer, it's late. To kill a mockingbird, arguably a children's book, also on the list. Well, I mean, I like it righty as a kid, I'm not sure. Anyway. Fine, but come on. Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's stoned. The very hungry caterpillar.
比如《下雪天》、《戴帽子的猫》、《野兽家园》、《夏洛特的网》。丹·科伊斯是一位作家，时间不早了。《杀死一只知更鸟》，可以说是一本儿童读物，也在名单上。嗯，我是说，我小时候喜欢它，我不确定。总之。好吧，但是拜托。《哈利·波特与魔法石》。《好饿的毛毛虫》。
The only books, quote unquote, for adults, on this list are 1984, Fahrenheit 451, and how to win friends and influence people by Dale Carnegie, love that that book is still on there. All told, seven of the ten books were for kids. Taking together they were checked out over two and a half million times. But the very bottom of the list, Dan Coise knows this little footnote. And it just said, you know, fun fact, good night moon.
这份名单上唯一的“成人”书籍是《1984》、《华氏451》和戴尔·卡内基的《人性的弱点》，我很喜欢这本书还在名单上。总而言之，十本书中有七本是给孩子看的。加在一起，它们被借阅了超过两百五十万次。但在名单的最底部，丹·科伊斯注意到了这个小脚注。它只是说，你知道，有趣的事实，《晚安，月亮》。
Of course one of the most beloved children's books of all time was not on the list. The footnote was almost like an apology, because if there's one title that you'd expect to be on the list, it's Good Night Moon. The famous picture book where the little toddler rabbits says Good Night to all the objects in its massive bedroom. Good night socks, Good Night clocks, Good Night, you know, Moon. I was really surprised not only because I know of its popularity, but because I have always sort of viewed it as a kind of platonically perfect children's picture book for the exact moment in the day when you most need a picture book.
当然，有史以来最受喜爱的儿童读物之一并没有出现在名单上。这个脚注几乎像是一种道歉，因为如果有一本书是你期望出现在名单上的，那就是《晚安，月亮》。那本著名的绘本，小兔子对它巨大卧室里的所有物体说晚安。晚安袜子，晚安时钟，晚安，你知道，月亮。我真的很惊讶，不仅因为我知道它的受欢迎程度，还因为我一直把它视为一种柏拉图式的完美儿童绘本，适合一天中你最需要绘本的那一刻。
That moment when you need your child to fall asleep, so you can finally take a shower or watch TV or do anything except parent. Still, the book had only been checked out about half as many times as the lowest drinking book on the list, but it wasn't because of lack of interest. No, it was because of one person. According to the New York Public Library, an influential children's librarian at the library, had disliked the story so much when it was published in 1947 that the library didn't even carry the book until 1972. And this librarian's name, according to the press release, was Anne Carroll Moore.
那一刻你需要你的孩子入睡，这样你终于可以洗个澡、看电视或做任何除了当父母以外的事情。尽管如此，这本书的借阅次数只有名单上借阅量最低的书的一半，但这并不是因为缺乏兴趣。不，这是因为一个人。据纽约公共图书馆称，该馆一位有影响力的儿童图书管理员在1947年这本书出版时非常不喜欢这个故事，以至于图书馆直到1972年才引进这本书。根据新闻稿，这位图书管理员的名字叫安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔。
Anne Carroll Moore was the head children's librarian at the New York Public Library for pretty much the whole first half of the 20th century. And from nearly three decades, she single-handedly kept Good Night Moon out of the entire library system. The children's librarian could just say no New York Public Library will stock this book and the idea of like children everywhere in the world growing to love Good Night Moon except for in New York City where they grew up sad and Good Night Moonless just seemed bananas to me. Now at this point, if you're imagining your stereotypical rule-mongering moralizing librarian giving you the stink eye, Dan Koyce says you don't need to imagine it.
安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔在20世纪上半叶的几乎整个时期都是纽约公共图书馆的儿童图书管理员主管。近三十年来，她凭一己之力将《晚安，月亮》拒之于整个图书馆系统之外。儿童图书管理员可以说不，纽约公共图书馆就不会收藏这本书，而全世界的孩子们都开始喜欢《晚安，月亮》，除了在纽约市，他们长大后感到悲伤且没有《晚安，月亮》，这对我来说简直太荒谬了。现在，如果你想象的是那种刻板印象中爱立规矩、爱说教的图书管理员给你白眼，丹·科伊斯说你不需要想象。
There are pictures. At the time that there were finally photographs of her taken, she was an older lady who looked like the quintessential bun in the hair, shushing librarian, who's a really easy villain. But as Dan would find out, Moore was and remains a very complicated historical figure. Because long before she became a villainous banner of books, and Carol Moore was a hero of children's literature, who left the world with one undeniably good thing. She pretty much single-handedly invented
有照片。在她最终被拍到照片的时候，她是一位老妇人，看起来就像典型的梳着发髻、爱嘘人的图书管理员，是一个非常容易塑造的反派。但正如丹所发现的，摩尔过去是，现在仍然是一个非常复杂的历史人物。因为早在她成为臭名昭著的禁书者之前，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔就是儿童文学的英雄，她给世界留下了一件不可否认的好事。她几乎凭一己之力发明了
the children's library. Julepore is a professor of history at Harvard and a staff writer for the New Yorker who wrote about Moore for the magazine. And she says that perhaps no single person has ever done more to get books into the hands of children. And she did so by creating a place for kids to read. So when you go into your neighborhood public library and there is a thing
儿童图书馆。吉尔·莱波雷是哈佛大学的历史学教授，《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，她曾为该杂志撰写过关于摩尔的文章。她说，也许没有哪个人在让书籍进入孩子们手中方面做得更多。她通过为孩子们创造一个阅读空间做到了这一点。所以当你走进你附近的公共图书馆时，有一个东西
called the children's room and they have potted plants there and they have toys and they have a cozy rug and a rocking chair and they have story hours and they have fun art on the walls. Like all that stuff was invented by Anne Carole Moore. Today with all the emphasis we place on instilling kids with love of reading, it's hard to imagine your local public library without a children's reading room. But LaPore says that before Moore came along,
叫做儿童阅览室，那里有盆栽植物，有玩具，有舒适的地毯和摇椅，有故事时间，墙上还有有趣的艺术品。所有这些都是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔发明的。今天，随着我们如此强调培养孩子对阅读的热爱，很难想象没有儿童阅览室的当地公共图书馆。但莱波雷说，在摩尔出现之前，
children weren't even allowed to enter the one place, they would be sure to find a book. Kids really couldn't go to libraries. Libraries were for grownups. The late 19th century saw some of the first public libraries being built in America. This was an age in which there was a surge in support for government-funded progressive institutions intended for the betterment of all. Or in the case of libraries, the betterment of everyone except children.
孩子们甚至不被允许进入那个他们肯定能找到书的地方。图书馆是为成年人准备的。19世纪末，美国建造了一些最早的公共图书馆。这是一个政府资助的进步机构支持激增的时代，旨在改善所有人的生活。或者在图书馆的情况下，改善除儿童以外的所有人的生活。
You had to be, I think, 14 or 16 in most places and in most places you had to be a boy. And the Brooklyn Public Schools had a policy that children below the third grade do not read well enough to profit from the use of library books. The thinking went that if you were too young to read, obviously there would be no need for you to go to the library. What good would that do to you? And if you were old enough to read that you were still a child going into a library which was full of trashy, romance novels and westerns would just corrupt your mind. And so certainly there's no reason for you to go into a library either.
在大多数地方，你必须年满14或16岁，而且在大多数地方，你必须是男孩。布鲁克林公立学校有一项政策，即三年级以下的孩子阅读能力不足以从使用图书馆书籍中获益。当时的观点是，如果你太小而不会阅读，显然就没有必要去图书馆。那对你有什么好处呢？如果你大到可以阅读，但你仍然是一个孩子，走进一个满是垃圾浪漫小说和西部小说的图书馆只会腐蚀你的思想。所以当然也没有理由让你去图书馆。
Gillipore says that for the children of the wealthy and middle classes, who often had their own small book collections at home, being banned from libraries wasn't really a problem. But it left the children of the poor with virtually no access to literature. It's completely bound up with class discrimination, right? Because it's not really till the 1920s that you have a very strict regulation against child labor. So the children of the poor are working, like they're not reading, they're not even learning to read.
吉尔·莱波雷说，对于富裕和中产阶级的孩子来说，他们家里通常有自己的小藏书，被禁止进入图书馆并不是什么大问题。但这让穷人的孩子几乎无法接触到文学。这完全与阶级歧视有关，对吧？因为直到1920年代，才有了非常严格的禁止童工的规定。所以穷人的孩子在工作，他们不读书，甚至没有学习阅读。
But then at the turn of this entry, Anne Carole Moore, the crusty old librarian who hated Good Night Moon, came along and flipped the purpose of the library on its head. So I was very surprised recently to read in an article someone described her as the quintessential librarian with the bun in her hair and shushing the children when in actual fact that was exactly what she did not do. Jan Pinbaro is an editor in Children's Book author, and she says that in the 1890s, more
但在世纪之交，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔，那个讨厌《晚安，月亮》的古板老图书管理员出现了，并彻底改变了图书馆的宗旨。所以我最近读到一篇文章时感到非常惊讶，有人形容她是典型的梳着发髻、对孩子们嘘声的图书管理员，而实际上这正是她没有做的事情。简·平巴罗是一位编辑和儿童书作者，她说在1890年代，摩尔
it was the most vocal and energetic among a small group of young progressive librarians who'd begun experimenting with a radical idea. What if they finally let kids into a library, stocked an area with children's books, and then made that area just for kids? And what she was trying to do, and this is what's really important, she was trying to provide a childhood to working class kids. She was trying to give them all the luxury and leisure of having a space with books that are made
是一小群年轻的进步图书管理员中最直言不讳、最有活力的人，他们开始尝试一个激进的想法。如果他们最终让孩子们进入图书馆，在区域内储备儿童读物，然后把那个区域专门留给孩子们呢？她试图做的是，这一点非常重要，她试图为工人阶级的孩子们提供一个童年。她试图给他们所有拥有一个有书的空间的奢侈和闲暇，这些书是为
for them to be able to read so that they would have, what we would think of now is, you know, way to address an achievement gap and she was trying to level that field. And in 1906, more got the chance to run this experiment on an unrivaled scale. The New York Public Library was building its iconic main branch at the corner of 42nd Street in Fifth Avenue, and it would feature a dedicated children's reading room that
他们制作的，让他们能够阅读，这样他们就会拥有我们现在认为的，你知道，解决成就差距的方法，她试图拉平那个领域。1906年，摩尔得到了在一个前所未有的规模上进行这项实验的机会。纽约公共图书馆正在第42街和第五大道交汇处建造其标志性的主馆，它将设有一个专门的儿童阅览室，
would be designed, stocked, and run by more. And there are just these incredible photographs of that children's room when it opened in 1911. The photos depict one of the earliest public spaces designed exclusively for kids. More started by borrowing the idea of kid-sized tables and chairs from kindergarten, but she took the concept even further. She had benches, windows seats, built at the bottoms of the windows, giant windows, but they're like pint size.
由摩尔设计、储备和管理。当那个儿童阅览室在1911年开放时，有一些令人难以置信的照片。这些照片描绘了最早专门为孩子们设计的公共空间之一。摩尔从幼儿园借用了儿童尺寸桌椅的想法，但她把这个概念推得更远。她有长凳，窗座，建在窗户底部，巨大的窗户，但它们是小尺寸的。
Like if you were five years old, you could sit in those window seats and your feet would touch the floor. More especially wanted to provide poor kids from the tenements, access to the beauty of the natural world. So she installed pink floor tiles to catch the light coming through the windows
就像如果你五岁，你可以坐在那些窗座上，你的脚会碰到地板。摩尔特别想为来自廉租房的贫困孩子提供接触自然世界之美的机会。所以她安装了粉红色的地砖来捕捉透过窗户射进来的光线
and then filled the room with shell collections, butterflies, and dozens of bowls of freshly cut flowers. And these children, a lot of them were start for nature, and they would line up for the chance to look at and smell the flowers when she brought them in. More took down the silent signs. The library was now space for puppet shows and musical performances and story hours, featuring stories in multiple languages, so that the children of immigrants who did not yet read or speak English would still feel welcome. But most importantly, more filled the shelves of the new reading room, with hundreds and eventually thousands of children's books, not locked in a cabinet or in a rich kid's nursery,
然后房间里摆满了贝壳收藏、蝴蝶和几十碗鲜切花。这些孩子，他们中的许多人渴望自然，当她把花带进来时，他们会排队等待看花和闻花香的机会。摩尔取下了安静的标志。图书馆现在是木偶戏、音乐表演和故事时间的空间，故事以多种语言呈现，这样那些还不会读或说英语的移民孩子也会感到受欢迎。但最重要的是，摩尔在新阅览室的书架上摆满了成百上千，最终是数千本儿童读物，不是锁在柜子里或富家孩子的育儿室里，
but out in the open, for any child to pick up, leave through, and read. And if a child liked the expensive book they were holding, they could take it home. The only requirement was that they signed their name in a big black ledger alongside a pledge. When I write my name in this book, I promise to take good care of the books I use in the library and at home and to obey the rules of the library.
而是放在外面，供任何孩子拿取、翻阅和阅读。如果孩子喜欢他们手里拿着的那本昂贵的书，他们可以把它带回家。唯一的要求是他们在厚厚的黑色账本上签下自己的名字，并附上一份誓言。当我在这本书上写下我的名字时，我承诺会好好爱护我在图书馆和家里使用的书籍，并遵守图书馆的规则。
And it was a kind of sanctified moment. of the books I used in the library and at home and to obey the rules of the library. And it was a kind of sanctified moment. The pledge turned the process of checking out a book into a child's first act of citizenship. The room was an overnight success. Rich and poor kids alike flocked to the library. And more began training librarians to establish new reading rooms throughout New York. Including Nella Larson, the prominent African-American writer who created the first children's room in Harlem. By 1913, just two years after the children's room opened, more could boast that one third of the volumes borrowed from the city's branch libraries were children's books.
那是一个神圣的时刻。我在图书馆和家里使用的书籍，并遵守图书馆的规则。那是一个神圣的时刻。这份誓言将借书的过程变成了孩子公民身份的第一次实践。这个房间一夜之间就成功了。富人和穷人的孩子都涌向图书馆。摩尔开始培训图书管理员在纽约各地建立新的阅览室。包括内拉·拉森，那位创造了哈莱姆区第一个儿童阅览室的杰出非裔美国作家。到1913年，也就是儿童阅览室开放仅两年后，摩尔就可以夸耀说，从城市分馆借出的书籍中，三分之一是儿童读物。
And children's rooms were springing up even more quickly in the rest of the country. By the end of the 1920s, by one estimate, there were perhaps as many as 1,500 children's rooms in the US alone. And her reach was really worldwide. And there are places and countries where people would say, well, if you walk into that library, you'll realize that that was touched by Anne Carole Moore.
儿童阅览室在全国其他地区也如雨后春笋般涌现。到1920年代末，据估计，仅在美国就有多达1500个儿童阅览室。她的影响力确实是全球性的。在一些国家和地方，人们会说，好吧，如果你走进那个图书馆，你会意识到那是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔触及过的地方。
The spread of Moore's reading remodel was also instrumental in establishing children's literature as literature. Moore convinced the library going public that books like the Velveteen Rabbit, Winnie the Pooh, and the works of Beatrix Potter were in fact art. In the 1920s, saw an explosion ined children's departments at major publishers, and prizes like the Newbury Medal, which more helped create. So for multiple generations of New York children, Anne Carole-Mar was the reason that the libraries became places that fostered their love of storytelling and love of books. But all this came with a crucial caveat, which is that Ankerl Moore's vision was never limited to simply creating a place for kids to read.
摩尔的阅读模式的传播对于将儿童文学确立为文学也起到了关键作用。摩尔说服了去图书馆的公众，像《绒布兔子》、《小熊维尼》和碧翠丝·波特的作品实际上是艺术。1920年代，主要出版商的儿童部门出现了爆炸式增长，像纽伯瑞奖这样的奖项也随之诞生，摩尔参与了该奖项的创建。因此，对于几代纽约儿童来说，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔是图书馆成为培养他们对讲故事和书籍热爱的地方的原因。但这一切都有一个关键的警告，那就是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的愿景从未局限于仅仅为孩子们创造一个阅读的地方。
From the beginning, it was also about what counted as children's literature. So even as she was letting more children than ever into the library, Moore was keeping all kinds of books out. And as the head of the children's department in the New York Public Library, she was in charge of choosing the books that the children's departments of all those libraries acquired. And the NYPL's purchases often set the standard for libraries nationwide. Back then, children's titles were only published once a year in fall. So every year, around the same time, more would make a list of her favorite upcoming books. And that list was used by other librarians across the country.
从一开始，它也关乎什么才算儿童文学。因此，即使她让比以往任何时候都多的孩子进入图书馆，摩尔也把各种各样的书拒之门外。作为纽约公共图书馆儿童部的主管，她负责选择所有这些图书馆的儿童部门所采购的书籍。而纽约公共图书馆的采购往往为全国的图书馆设定了标准。那时，儿童读物每年只在秋季出版一次。所以每年，在同一时间，摩尔都会列出一份她最喜欢的即将出版的书籍清单。而那份清单被全国各地的其他图书管理员所使用。
So if you ran a library in Dubuque, Iowa, and you were trying to figure out, well, what am I going to spend my budget on? You just go right down the list, you go, I'm going to buy one of this, two of this, three of this, one of this, oh, none of this, whatever. You would use that list to guide your purchasing?
所以如果你在爱荷华州迪比克经营一家图书馆，你正试图弄清楚，好吧，我要把预算花在什么上面？你只需顺着名单往下看，你会说，我要买一本这个，两本这个，三本这个，一本这个，哦，不要这个，随便什么。你会用那份清单来指导你的采购吗？
More also had a regular review column. The parents and librarians alike used to decide which books were worth buying and which weren't. You would use that list to guide your purchasing? More also had a regular review column. The parents and librarians alike used to decide which books were worth buying and which weren't. So she's the most dominant children's book reviewer in the country, but then because she was also the chief purchaser for books, she quickly accumulates really far too much power. At the height of her career in the 1920s and 30s, she was like the Anna Win-Tor of Kids Lit.
摩尔还有一个定期的评论专栏。家长和图书管理员都用它来决定哪些书值得买，哪些不值得。你会用那份清单来指导你的采购吗？摩尔还有一个定期的评论专栏。家长和图书管理员都用它来决定哪些书值得买，哪些不值得。所以她是全国最有影响力的儿童书评论家，但因为她也是书籍的首席采购员，她很快积累了太多的权力。在1920和30年代她职业生涯的巅峰时期，她就像儿童文学界的安娜·温图尔。
Editors and authors were routinely seen walking up the steps of the public library's main branch between the two marble lions to drop off their books and await Morris verdict. If they were lucky, she'd send back notes for suggested changes, which they would doodfully incorporate into the final draft. Others weren't so fortunate.
编辑和作者经常被看到走上公共图书馆主馆的台阶，在两座大理石狮子之间，放下他们的书，等待摩尔的判决。如果他们幸运的话，她会寄回建议修改的笔记，他们会恭敬地将其纳入最终草稿。其他人就没有那么幸运了。
The story about Anne Carole Morrell, though no one, including her biographers, knows whether this was apocryphal or not, was that she actually had a custom-made rubber stamp that read, not recommended for purchase by expert, and that if she didn't like your book, she would stamp that on your book, and you, that's it, your book's dead.
关于安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的故事，虽然没有人，包括她的传记作者，知道这是否是杜撰的，是说她实际上有一个定制的橡皮图章，上面写着“专家不建议购买”，如果她不喜欢你的书，她会在你的书上盖上那个章，然后你，就这样，你的书完了。
No one's gonna order your book better luck next time. And there were a lot of manuscripts not recommended for purchase by expert because Anne Caromore had very specific tastes in children's literature. She may have been a great advocate of children's books as art, but in her zeal to protect kids from the horrors of poverty and urban life, more almost invariably favored magical once upon a time stories that felt pastoral and tweey. The whole point was for them to take the less fortunate into their warm bougie embrace. So her favorite children's books, the ones that she approved, certainly weren't meant to represent
没有人会订购你的书，下次好运吧。有很多手稿被专家建议不购买，因为安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔对儿童文学有非常具体的品味。她可能是一位伟大的儿童文学艺术倡导者，但在她保护孩子免受贫困和城市生活恐怖的狂热中，摩尔几乎总是偏爱那些感觉田园诗般、矫揉造作的魔法“很久很久以前”的故事。重点是让他们把不幸的人带入他们温暖的资产阶级怀抱。所以她最喜欢的儿童读物，那些她批准的，肯定不是为了代表
anything that a child certainly weren't meant to represent anything that a child might actually see or experience in his or her everyday life. They were meant to be little mini escapes into this magical world of talking animals and rabbits and waste coats and whatnot. To be honest, this is kind of where most of my experts for this story get off the ankle more train. Like she was a sharp-eyed critic. It's just, it's not my eye, so I'm trying to be charitable here. Say, like, you know, like she likes gooey. And she likes super sweet. And she likes silly animals that talk.
任何孩子在日常生活中可能真正看到或经历的事情。它们注定是进入这个充满会说话的动物、兔子、背心之类的魔法世界的小小逃避。老实说，这就是我为这个故事请的大多数专家离开安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔这趟列车的地方。就像她是一位目光敏锐的评论家。只是，那不是我的眼光，所以我在这里尽量宽容一点。说，就像，你知道，她喜欢粘糊糊的。她喜欢超级甜的。她喜欢会说话的傻动物。
Because Winnie the Pooh is great, right? But for a few decades of children's literature, from the 19 teens to the 1920s, pretty much everything coming out of the publishers was very poo. Meanwhile there were almost no books for kids that took place in cities, no books for kids that depicted real world problems, and very few children's books containing messy ideas or ambiguous endings, stories with those qualities never made it past more. Although sometimes a book can meet all of Moore's criteria,
因为《小熊维尼》很棒，对吧？但在儿童文学的几十年里，从1910年代到1920年代，出版商出版的几乎所有东西都非常“维尼”。与此同时，几乎没有关于城市中孩子的故事，没有关于现实世界问题的书，也很少有包含混乱想法或模棱两可结局的儿童读物，具有这些品质的故事从未通过摩尔这一关。虽然有时一本书可以满足摩尔的所有标准，
and she would still have it killed, for reasons known only to her. Do you think more, you said she's a pretty sharp-eyed critic. Do you think she had a kind of systematized notion of her own yaykeeping rules, or was she just like shooting from the hip. You know, I have no idea. I think she was drunk with power. Like, I think she loved being the lady in charge. Like, I think she just loved having the entire publishing industry at her
但她仍然会把它毙掉，原因只有她自己知道。你认为摩尔，你说她是一位目光敏锐的评论家。你认为她有一种系统化的“是/否”规则概念，还是她只是随心所欲？你知道，我不知道。我认为她被权力冲昏了头脑。就像，我认为她喜欢成为负责人的女士。就像，我认为她只是喜欢让整个出版业都听命于她。
back in call. And she thinks she's right. And she has no doubts about it. Like, she thinks she's right and she has no doubts about it. Like she thinks she's right. But even as Anne Carroll Moore held the publishing world in her iron grip, a small group of preschool teachers were busy writing stories for kids that embodied everything in children's literature that Moore hated. Their stories would go on to influence an entire generation of children's book authors, and they worked just a few blocks away at an experimental school in Greenwich Village, called Bank Street. Bank Street came along and said that picture books ought to be stories about modern urban
她认为自己是对的。她对此毫无疑问。就像她认为自己是对的，她对此毫无疑问。就像她认为自己是对的。但即使安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔以铁腕控制着出版界，一小群学前班老师正忙着为孩子们写故事，这些故事体现了儿童文学中摩尔所憎恨的一切。他们的故事将继续影响整整一代儿童书作者，而且他们就在几个街区外，在格林威治村的一所实验学校工作，名叫班克街。班克街出现并说绘本应该是关于现代城市生活的故事。
life. Leonard Marcus is a historian of children's literature, and he says that the Bank Street Cooperative School for Student Teachers, founded by the great educational reformer, Lucy's Brock Mitchell, was in many ways the ancestor of today's progressive schools. They believed that teachers should let children guide their own learning experience. And it just so happened that when people trained as teachers at Bank Street, they didn't read textbooks. They were trying to write stories for children.
伦纳德·马库斯是一位儿童文学历史学家，他说由伟大的教育改革家露西·斯普拉格·米切尔创立的班克街学生教师合作学校，在许多方面是当今进步学校的祖先。他们相信老师应该让孩子引导他们自己的学习体验。碰巧的是，当人们在班克街接受教师培训时，他们不读教科书。他们试图为孩子们写故事。
So the future teachers would really know from their own experience what kinds of stories are meaningful to kids at different ages. And when the teachers tried to write stories for the youngest kids at Bank Street, they noticed something important. Children are interested in the world. They find themselves in. Certainly there are children who have flights of fancy and think about dragons and wizards and whatnot. But anyone who's had a four-year-old knows that often the thing that is most interesting to them is the garbage truck that comes by every Tuesday afternoon. So instead of a book about magical realms, a book published by Bank Street would be
所以未来的老师们会真正从他们自己的经验中知道，什么样的故事对不同年龄的孩子是有意义的。当老师们试图为班克街最小的孩子写故事时，他们注意到了一些重要的事情。孩子们对他们所处的世界感兴趣。当然，有些孩子有奇思妙想，会想到龙、巫师之类的东西。但任何带过四岁孩子的人都知道，通常对他们来说最有趣的事情是每周二下午经过的垃圾车。所以，与其写一本关于魔法王国的书，不如写一本班克街出版的书
about the child's more immediate world, focusing on the kinds of things that small children in cities really, really like, like street cars and a trip to the grocery store and steam shovels. Designed for the very young, these stories rarely had plots. They were more like games, circular, interactive, and open-ended. Plot wasn't the most important thing at Bank Street. Much more important was being invited to participate. Bank street stories might depict a jackhammer or a train going by and then ask the child to imitate those sounds,
关于孩子更直接的世界，专注于城市里的小孩子真正非常喜欢的东西，比如电车、去杂货店和蒸汽铲。这些为幼儿设计的故事很少有情节。它们更像是游戏，循环的、互动的、开放式的。情节在班克街并不是最重要的。更重要的是被邀请参与。班克街的故事可能会描绘一个手提钻或一列火车经过，然后要求孩子模仿那些声音，
but also in the other sounds they might feel like imitating. Giving the child an opening to expand them infinitely if they wanted to, not just sit there and listen to the once-a-pound-a-time story. All of which pretty much stood in diametric opposition to the philosophy of Ancaro Mor. The idea that the everyday life of a child with no magic whatsoever involved in it is something that ought to be immortalized in a children's book. Definitely was not, that was not Ancaro Mor's speed. To more, these plotless games for the very young, with their emphasis on experience over
但也包括他们可能想模仿的其他声音。给孩子一个机会，如果他们愿意，可以无限扩展，而不是仅仅坐在那里听“很久很久以前”的故事。所有这些几乎与安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的哲学截然相反。孩子们的日常生活，没有任何魔法参与其中，是应该在儿童读物中永垂不朽的东西。绝对不是，那不是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的速度。对摩尔来说，这些为幼儿准备的无情节游戏，强调体验胜过
imagination, simply didn't count as literature. She made sure they weren't included in her annual list of best books. She didn't even dare to write her usual scathing review. In the very first Bank Street books, I'll be here in now series, stayed off the library shelves. But Bank Street's earliest called the Here and Now series, stayed off the library shelves. But Bank Street's earliest stories had another more fundamental problem. I think the stories in the first year now,
想象力，根本算不上文学。她确保它们没有被列入她的年度最佳图书清单。她甚至不敢写她通常那种尖刻的评论。第一批班克街书籍，“此时此地”系列，被挡在了图书馆书架之外。但班克街最早的“此时此地”系列，被挡在了图书馆书架之外。但班克街最早的故事还有另一个更根本的问题。我认为“此时此地”第一本书里的故事，
book, they're boring. Mac Barnett is the author of over 40 children's books. And he says that from the point of view of craft, which is to say, of actually capturing a kid's attention, Bank Street's first attempts at children's literature were terrible. Although they were new at the time and feel sort of radical, they are being written according to a formula.
它们很无聊。麦克·巴内特是40多本儿童读物的作者。他说，从工艺的角度来看，也就是真正吸引孩子注意力的角度来看，班克街对儿童文学的最初尝试是糟糕的。虽然它们在当时是新的，感觉有点激进，但它们是按照公式编写的。
You can see the philosophy, they're theory driven. The writing in most of these early stories came across as stiff and formulaic. There were only occasional illustrations with no real interplay between image and words. And every story started with an introduction describing his pedagogical intent. Here's one from a chapter called The Sky Scraper.
你可以看到其中的哲学，它们是理论驱动的。这些早期故事中大多数的写作显得生硬且公式化。只有偶尔的插图，图像和文字之间没有真正的互动。而且每个故事都以一段描述其教学意图的介绍开头。这里有一个来自名为《摩天大楼》的章节。
The story tries to assemble into a related form many facts well known to seven-year-olds and to present the whole as a modern industrial process. So right there, like, as soon as your story begins with a mission statement, it's already over. Like, the thing is lying on the floor. The writers at Bank Street were just as blinded by their own dogma, as Anne Carrollmore, and with the same end result.
这个故事试图将许多七岁孩子熟知的知识组装成一种相关的形式，并将整体呈现为一个现代工业过程。所以就在那里，就像，一旦你的故事以使命宣言开头，它就已经结束了。就像，那东西躺在地板上。班克街的作家们和安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔一样被他们自己的教条所蒙蔽，结果也一样。
Their stories could never achieve their high-minded aspirations, because they felt stale and doctrinaire. But in the 1930s, one person managed to make the Bank Street style come alive, the future author of Good Night Moon. Margaret Wise Brown was a teacher at Bank Street who didn't want to be a teacher. She wanted to be a famous literary writer. She wanted her short stories to be published
他们的故事永远无法实现他们高尚的愿望，因为它们感觉陈旧且教条。但在1930年代，一个人成功地让班克街风格活了起来，也就是《晚安，月亮》的未来作者。玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗是班克街的一名老师，她不想当老师。她想成为一名著名的文学作家。她想让她的短篇小说发表
in the New Yorker, but that wasn't going to happen. And honestly, neither was the teaching thing. Like all of her evaluations say like, you know, I don't think she's going to be a great teacher. So she couldn't write for adults and she couldn't teach kids. But when Margaret Wise Brown tried to write Bank Street stories for kids, something weird happened. They were good.
在《纽约客》上，但这不会发生。老实说，教学这件事也不会。就像她所有的评估都说，你知道，我不认为她会成为一名伟大的老师。所以她不能为成年人写作，也不能教孩子。但当玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗试图为孩子们写班克街故事时，奇怪的事情发生了。它们很好。
In Brown's hands, these stories for the very young, with their circular rhythms and game-like structures, were transformed into something new. The big bank street realization, I think, from Margot Wise Brown is that through talking to kids, she discovered her purpose as a writer, because she found that kids are the best audience for poetry. Margot Wise Brown's books were more than stories or games.
在布朗手中，这些为幼儿准备的故事，以其循环的节奏和游戏般的结构，被转化为新的东西。我认为玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗从班克街得到的最大启示是，通过与孩子交谈，她发现了自己作为作家的目的，因为她发现孩子是诗歌最好的听众。玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗的书不仅仅是故事或游戏。
They were poems for children who were still open to novel ways of seeing and describing the world around them. Consider a story from a series of books Brown first started in collaboration with Bank Street, the noisy books. The story is about a little dog who hears a tiny, almost imperceptible noise and tries to identify it. Brown asked the reader to guess what the sound might be, but instead of suggesting things that we might think of as making sounds, she points to things that don't. So it says, was it butter melting? Was it a little blue flower growing? Was it a skyscraper scraping the sky? The early Bank Street books would have simply asked the reader to register that a skyscraper was tall, but Brown was encouraging them to perceive it in an entirely new poetic fashion.
它们是为那些仍然对观察和描述周围世界的新颖方式持开放态度的孩子们写的诗。考虑一个布朗最初与班克街合作开始的系列书籍中的故事，《吵闹书》。故事是关于一只小狗听到一个微小的、几乎无法察觉的声音，并试图识别它。布朗要求读者猜猜那声音可能是什么，但她没有建议我们认为会发出声音的东西，而是指出了那些不会发出声音的东西。所以它说，是黄油融化的声音吗？是一朵小蓝花生长的声音吗？是摩天大楼刮擦天空的声音吗？早期的班克街书籍只会简单地要求读者记录下摩天大楼很高，但布朗鼓励他们以一种全新的诗意方式去感知它。
Sky-Scriper scraping the sky and suddenly you can hear it. Brown was also a master of writing poetry that worked in tandem with the art in a book, particularly by deploying page turns. Your average contemporary children's picture book will contain 14 page turns, and most authors will use these moments to build suspense. If you want to know what happens, you've got to turn the page. But Markerwise Brown's page turns, just as often zig-zag, setting up patterns and then breaking them. So you get, was it an ant crawling?
摩天大楼刮擦天空，突然你就能听到了。布朗也是编写与书中艺术协同工作的诗歌的大师，特别是通过运用翻页。你当代普通的儿童绘本将包含14次翻页，大多数作者会利用这些时刻来制造悬念。如果你想知道发生了什么，你必须翻页。但玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗的翻页，同样经常是之字形的，建立模式然后打破它们。所以你会得到，是一只蚂蚁在爬吗？
Was it a bee-wondering? Page turn. Was it an elephant tiptoeing down the stairs? And you move across that page turn from this very intimate domestic scene of a dog very small on the page, listening at the stairs, to this giant two-page spread this elephant and the scale is gigantic he barely fits in the frame. Page turns like these can be disorienting
是一只蜜蜂在徘徊吗？翻页。是一头大象在楼梯上踮着脚尖走吗？你穿过那个翻页，从这个非常亲密的家庭场景，一只狗在页面上很小，在楼梯上听着，到这个巨大的双页跨页，这头大象，比例是巨大的，他几乎塞不进框架。像这样的翻页可能会让人迷失方向
and that's the point. You feel like you're constantly crashing into new worlds and discovering new things which again like that's what being a kid feels like a lot of the time. Brown also helped change the look and feel of children's books. As an editor at Scott Publishing, a small imprint associated with Fang Street, she developed one of the first tactile books, featuring lambs with real toy bells and bunnies with real cotton ball tails, turning the book into a physically interactive object. But perhaps Margaret Wise Brown's greatest accomplishment was bridging the divide between the two factions of children's literature. Her stories provided interactive experiences
这就是重点。你感觉自己不断地撞进新的世界，发现新的东西，这又像，这就是做孩子很多时候的感觉。布朗还帮助改变了儿童读物的外观和感觉。作为班克街相关的小型出版商斯科特出版公司的编辑，她开发了最早的触觉书之一，特色是带有真正玩具铃铛的羔羊和带有真正棉球尾巴的兔子，将书变成了一个物理上的互动对象。但也许玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗最大的成就是弥合了儿童文学两个派别之间的鸿沟。她的故事提供了互动体验
focusing on everyday things, but they also contained elements like talking animals, and they weren't afraid to lean into nostalgia and whimsy. So instead of rejecting the documentary realism of Bank Street, or the magical escapism of Anker Almoor, Brown found a way to combine them. And nowhere did she do this better than in Good Night Moon. For Good Night Moon, Brown took inspiration from something in her own daily life. Whenever she woke up feeling sad and struggled to get out of bed, she'd perform a kind of ritual. and struggled to get out of bed. She'd perform a kind of ritual.
专注于日常事物，但它们也包含像会说话的动物这样的元素，而且它们不害怕倾向于怀旧和奇思妙想。所以，布朗没有拒绝班克街的纪录片现实主义，也没有拒绝安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔的魔法逃避主义，而是找到了一种结合它们的方法。在《晚安，月亮》中，她做得最好。对于《晚安，月亮》，布朗从她自己日常生活中的某件事中汲取了灵感。每当她醒来感到悲伤并挣扎着起床时，她就会进行一种仪式。并挣扎着起床。她会进行一种仪式。
She would line bed and look around and focus on different objects in the room that she was glad to have in her presence and would essentially count her blessings. She would take in the books on her shelf, the pattern of her sheets, the view from her window. And then, when she was finished,
她会躺在床上环顾四周，专注于房间里她很高兴拥有的不同物体，本质上是在数她的祝福。她会观察书架上的书，床单的图案，窗外的景色。然后，当她完成后，
she would write it all down in a list. Get up and face the day. For Good Night Moon, Brown simply reversed the ritual. It's a list you read to fall asleep. What are we gonna read today? Good Night Moon. The beginning of Good Night Moon really is nothing more than a list. Documenting the objects in the bedroom of a little bunny getting ready to go to sleep. In the great green room, there was a telephone, and a red balloon, and a picture of... There's no plot, no tension, just things. The cow jumping over the moon.
她会把这一切写成清单。起床面对新的一天。对于《晚安，月亮》，布朗只是反转了这个仪式。这是一份你读着读着就会入睡的清单。我们今天要读什么？《晚安，月亮》。《晚安，月亮》的开头确实只不过是一份清单。记录了一个准备睡觉的小兔子的卧室里的物体。在那个大绿房间里，有一部电话，一个红气球，还有一张……没有情节，没有紧张感，只有东西。牛跳过月亮。
But then you move into the second section unannounced. Good night bears. Good night chairs. And yet everyone knows what to do when they get there. Good night kittens. Which is chime in. And good night mittens. Right.
但随后你毫无预兆地进入了第二部分。晚安，熊。晚安，椅子。然而每个人都知道到了那里该做什么。晚安，小猫。也就是跟着念。晚安，手套。对。
What about this one next to it? And then you come to the page that says, good night, nobody. Nobody. Well, what do you do with that? And it's up to the child to decide. And that's pure bank street. And I would say pure magic. And Anne-Karol Moore hated it.
旁边那个是什么？然后你翻到写着“晚安，虚无”的那一页。虚无。好吧，你拿它怎么办？这取决于孩子自己决定。那是纯粹的班克街风格。我会说纯粹的魔法。而安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔讨厌它。
Oh, yeah, she hated it. Yeah, she was totally opposed to it. By the time Good Night Moon came out in 1947, Moore was technically retired from her job at the library. But even in retirement, she remained in control of the children's department, showing up at meetings uninvited and making sure her policies remained in place. Even when her successor would like try to change the meeting room at the last minute, and Carol Moore was still just magically show up and run that meeting.
哦，是的，她讨厌它。是的，她完全反对它。《晚安，月亮》在1947年出版时，摩尔在技术上已经从图书馆的工作中退休了。但即使在退休后，她仍然控制着儿童部，不请自来地参加会议，并确保她的政策保持不变。即使当她的继任者想在最后一刻改变会议室时，安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔仍然会神奇地出现并主持那次会议。
Leonard Marcus says we know what more thought of Good Night Moon because the New York Public Library maintained internal reviews of every book that was submitted to them. And I was secretly shown the report on Good Night Moon, secretly because nobody outside of the library staff was ever supposed to see them, but I found someone who's willing to leak the report to me. The report described Good Night Moon as an unbearably sentimental piece of work.
伦纳德·马库斯说，我们知道摩尔对《晚安，月亮》的看法，因为纽约公共图书馆保留了提交给他们的每一本书的内部评论。我被秘密地展示了关于《晚安，月亮》的报告，秘密是因为图书馆工作人员以外的任何人都不应该看到它们，但我找到了一个愿意把报告泄露给我的人。报告将《晚安，月亮》描述为一部令人难以忍受的感伤作品。
Which is just funny when I think of unbearable sentimentality as like the jacket copy of a book you write for Anne Carole Moore. But it didn't matter. Good Night Moon had the stink of Bank Street on it. The book was not recommended for purchase by expert. Good Night Moon sold only a handful of copies before more or less disappearing from stores. Mar-O has brown, but I'd only a few years later, in 1952. Following complications from a surgery, she was just 42 years old. But even if she didn't know it, it was right around this time
这很有趣，因为我认为令人难以忍受的感伤就像你为安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔写的书的封底文案。但这并不重要。《晚安，月亮》身上有班克街的味道。这本书没有被专家推荐购买。《晚安，月亮》在几乎从商店消失之前只卖出了几本。玛格丽特·怀兹·布朗，但在几年后的1952年。手术并发症后，她年仅42岁。但即使她不知道，也就在这个时候
that Good Night Moon's fortune to begin to change. It was the era of the baby boom. Pop psychology was in. And parents eager to raise their children using the latest methods devoured books and articles about what children needed at various stages of life. And in 1951, there was a column saying that if you have a two-year-old and he is not going to sleep, read them this book, Good Night Moon. It'll work.
《晚安，月亮》的命运开始改变。那是婴儿潮时代。流行心理学很流行。渴望用最新方法抚养孩子的父母贪婪地阅读关于孩子在生命各个阶段需要什么的各种书籍和文章。1951年，有一篇专栏文章说，如果你有一个两岁的孩子，他不想睡觉，读这本书给他听，《晚安，月亮》。它会奏效的。
And sure enough, 1951 is when sales of Good Night Moon at bookstores slowly began to rise. And that book was read by kids in the late 50s who grew into adults, who remembered reading that book more than any other book, so bought it for their own kids, who then grew into adults, who loved that book more than any other. And that's how it happened. It happened in a way that maybe is most terrifying to Anker Almore,
果然，1951年是《晚安，月亮》在书店的销量开始缓慢上升的时候。那本书被50年代末的孩子们读过，他们长大成人，记得读过那本书胜过任何其他书，所以为他们自己的孩子买了它，他们后来长大成人，比任何其他书都更爱那本书。事情就是这样发生的。它发生的某种方式可能是安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔最恐惧的，
Anker Almore is sort of irrelevant to the success of that book. In 1972, the New York Public Library caved and finally put Good Night Moon on the shelves. At that point, it was selling nearly 100,000 copies a year. As of 2017, it sold nearly 48 million. Leonard Marcus says that Clamot heard the illustrator of Goodnight Moon showed him a fan letter once. He was from a mother whose little boy had wanted the book read to him every night,
安妮·卡罗尔·摩尔与那本书的成功无关。1972年，纽约公共图书馆屈服了，终于把《晚安，月亮》放上了书架。那时，它每年销售近10万册。截至2017年，它已售出近4800万册。伦纳德·马库斯说，《晚安，月亮》的插画家克莱门特·赫德曾经给他看了一封粉丝来信。那是来自一位母亲，她的小男孩想让他每晚读这本书，
six times, from start to finish. And one night after the sixth reading, she laid the book down on his bed, and he stood up. It was open to a page with one of the color, full color illustrations of the room. And he put his foot down on the page, and then he burst into tears. His mother didn't know what to make of it,
六次，从头到尾。有一天晚上，在第六次阅读后，她把书放在他的床上，他站了起来。书翻到了房间全彩插图的那一页。他把脚放在书页上，然后大哭起来。他的母亲不知道该怎么办，
so she just waited to see what would happen next. And then he put his second foot down and just completely melted down. And then she realized what was happening. And she wrote to him and said, my son wanted to, was trying to climb inside your room. That's how real it is to him. Jillipore said she also came across a letter.
所以她只是等着看接下来会发生什么。然后他放下了第二只脚，彻底崩溃了。然后她意识到发生了什么。她写信给他，说，我儿子想，试图爬进你的房间。这就是对他来说有多真实。Jillipore说她也偶然发现了一封信。
But this one was about Anne Carroll more. More died in 1961, and upon hearing of her death, a prominent editor wrote to a friend, quote, much as she did for children's books, I can't help feeling her influence was baleful on the whole. Am I wrong? It's an incredibly powerful, I mean, final epitaph on her life. It seems totally fair to me. She did an extraordinary amount for children's literature and for children early on, and then I think she kind of lost her grip.
但这封信更多是关于Anne Carroll Moore的。Moore于1961年去世，听到她去世的消息后，一位著名的编辑写信给一位朋友，引用道，尽管她为儿童读物做了很多贡献，但我还是忍不住觉得她整体上的影响是灾难性的。我错了吗？这对我来说是一个令人难以置信的强大，我的意思是，对她一生的最终墓志铭。我觉得这完全公平。她在儿童文学和儿童早期教育方面做了大量非凡的工作，然后我认为她有点失去了控制。
Lapor, however, is also quick to defend more, and so is Dan Coise. Walk into the children's reading room of any library in the country at story time, he says. And you're witnessing her contribution. The notion that the library's mission remains to serve children and to make them feel at home in the space and to make them feel like reading is a thing for them is remarkable and I don't want to lose sight of that. And to make them feel like reading is a thing for them is
然而，Lapor也很快为Moore辩护，Dan Coise也是如此。他说，走进全国任何图书馆的儿童阅览室，在讲故事的时候。你正在见证她的贡献。图书馆的使命仍然是服务儿童，让他们在空间里感到宾至如归，让他们觉得阅读是属于他们的，这种观念是了不起的，我不想忽视这一点。让他们觉得阅读是属于他们的，是
Remarkable and I don't watch a lose Side of that and for all her faults and flaws. That's because of her If you go back and look at the list of the New York public libraries top 10 checked out books a lot of the titles are ones more Probably would have banned that she's still been around. After all, where the wild things are, the snowy day, the very hungry caterpillar, they all owe something to the work of Market Wise Brown and the teachers at Bankstreet. But the fact that the top 10 list is mostly children's books in the first place, that's something we owe to Anne Carole Moore.
了不起的，我不想忽视这一点，尽管她有所有的缺点和瑕疵。那是因为她。如果你回去看看纽约公共图书馆借阅量前10名的书单，很多书名都是Moore如果还在世的话可能会禁止的。毕竟，《野兽家园》、《下雪天》、《好饿的毛毛虫》，它们都归功于Margaret Wise Brown和Bank Street老师们的工作。但前10名榜单主要是儿童读物这一事实，首先，这是我们欠Anne Carroll Moore的。
["The End of the World"] Next up, the story of a doll that delighted children and possibly terrified adults at the New York Public Library after this. Okay, so I'm here with Joe Rosenberg. So one of the reasons why we invented this little code section is there's often little outtakes from the story that we couldn't quite fit in. And I hear you have some really good bonus material for me. Yeah.
["世界末日"] 接下来，在纽约公共图书馆里，一个让孩子们高兴，可能让大人们感到恐惧的玩偶的故事，就在这之后。好的，我和Joe Rosenberg在一起。所以我们发明这个小代码环节的原因之一是，故事中经常有一些我们无法完全放入的小花絮。我听说你有一些非常好的额外材料给我。是的。
And I wanted to save it for the code up because it is the one subplot in this whole saga that is maybe the thing I most wanted to talk about. But if we talked about it in the main piece, it would just derail the story. Like it would just bring the entire story to a crashing hole. I know exactly what you mean, I'm totally bit there. Yeah, yeah, and it's because whenever this comes up, everyone is just like, wim-wim-wim-wim-wim-wim, stop. What? And it is the story of Nicholas Nickerbacher. I already love it.
我想把它留到代码环节，因为这是整个传奇中唯一一个我最想谈论的子情节。但如果我们把它放在主要部分，它会破坏故事。就像它会把整个故事带到一个崩溃的洞里。我完全明白你的意思，我完全在那里。是的，是的，这是因为每当这件事出现时，每个人都像，呜呜呜呜呜呜，停。什么？这就是Nicholas Nickerbacher的故事。我已经爱上它了。
So who is Nicholas Nickerbacher? And how does it fit into the story? So Nicholas Nickerbacher was this creation of Anne Caramore that perhaps represents everything that is most wonderful and most problematic about her all at once, because Nicholas was this little wooden articulated doll that more like to use to talk to kids. It was about eight inches high. And when she was in the reading room, if a young child was acting shy, perhaps because
那么Nicholas Nickerbacher是谁？它又是如何融入故事的呢？所以Nicholas Nickerbacher是Anne Carroll Moore的创造，也许它同时代表了关于她最美妙和最成问题的一切，因为Nicholas是一个小木制关节玩偶，Moore喜欢用它来和孩子们交谈。它大约八英寸高。当她在阅览室时，如果一个年幼的孩子表现得很害羞，也许是因为
their English wasn't very good yet, and she wanted to bring them out of their shell, she would pull this doll out of her handbag and basically say, I want to introduce you to Nicholas. That's so sweet. I actually kind of like that sort of a Mr. Rogers kind of quality to it. So was Nicholas like, did Nicholas have a certain personality, or was he just kind of in Carol Moore? Yeah, so Nicholas apparently was a little Dutch boy with like a little Dutch boy outfit, which I kind of suspect was a nod to the idea that so many of the children using the reading room were immigrants.
他们的英语还不是很好，她想让他们走出自己的壳，她会从手提包里拿出这个玩偶，基本上说，我想把你介绍给Nicholas。太甜了。我其实有点喜欢那种罗杰斯先生的品质。那么Nicholas是，Nicholas有某种个性，还是他只是有点像Anne Carroll Moore？是的，所以Nicholas显然是一个穿着荷兰小男孩服装的小荷兰男孩，我有点怀疑这是对使用阅览室的许多孩子是移民这一想法的致敬。
But more importantly, she would tell the children that Nicholas came alive at night and had access to this kind of magical world, hiding just behind this one. And so the idea was that you might think you were in a normal old boring room, but when Nicholas showed up, he would help reveal the magic all around you. Right. I mean, that just reminds me of all the types of books that she was really fond of. I mean, she always liked those escapist stories.
但更重要的是，她会告诉孩子们Nicholas在晚上活了过来，并且可以进入这个隐藏在这个房间后面的神奇世界。所以这个想法是，你可能认为你是在一个普通、陈旧、无聊的房间里，但当Nicholas出现时，他会帮助揭示你周围的魔法。对。我的意思是，这让我想起了她真正喜欢的所有类型的书。我的意思是，她总是喜欢那些逃避现实的故事。
Right. Very once upon a time, none of that boring, bank street stuff. Right, right. No garbage trucks, no city problems. Right, where you just get the child to the light in the mere room itself. No, you know, so the whole point of Nicholas was to propel the child into these flights of imagination that would take them beyond here and now
对。非常“很久很久以前”，没有那些无聊的Bank Street的东西。对，对。没有垃圾车，没有城市问题。对，你只是让孩子在房间本身就感到高兴。没有，你知道，所以Nicholas的全部意义在于推动孩子进入这些想象力的飞行，带他们超越此时此地
into these magical nighttime realms. I mean, that all seems pretty wonderful. That seems like a good librarian thing to do. You mentioned that it was kind of, it represented the problematic way in which she operated. How did it manage to do that? Yeah, so the problem is that as with so many things related to ant-cural more, there is a dark side to Nicholas Nickerbacher.
进入这些神奇的夜间领域。我的意思是，这一切看起来都很美妙。这看起来像是一个好的图书管理员应该做的事情。你提到它有点，它代表了她运作的有问题的方式。它是怎么做到这一点的？是的，所以问题在于，正如与Anne Carroll Moore有关的许多事情一样，Nicholas Nickerbacher也有黑暗的一面。
And in this case, it's that Nicholas' life was not restricted to the confines of the reading room. Dan Coise was telling me that apparently after a while, people started noticing that Moore was carrying Nicholas around with her, like almost all the time. I can only speculate as to what people thought about. And Carol Moore carrying around Nicholas Nicarbacher. There are photos of her just like out in the park in Bryant Park, I assume, just carrying Nicholas the doll under her arm.
在这种情况下，Nicholas的生活并不局限于阅览室的范围。Dan Coise告诉我，显然过了一段时间，人们开始注意到Moore几乎一直带着Nicholas。我只能推测人们对Anne Carroll Moore带着Nicholas Nickerbacher的想法。有她的照片，就像在公园里，我想是在布莱恩特公园，只是把Nicholas这个玩偶夹在胳膊下。
And I don't know if it was her way of connecting to children or if she just had some kind of weird-ass fixation. And I don't know if it was her way of connecting to children or if she just had some kind of weird-ass fixation. Well, I mean, I can see his concern or maybe other people's concern, but like a generous reading of this is like, you know, she had a cool companion, she had a doll, she talked to kids, it seems like it seems okay to me so far.
我不知道这是她与孩子联系的方式，还是她只是有一种奇怪的执着。我不知道这是她与孩子联系的方式，还是她只是有一种奇怪的执着。好吧，我的意思是，我能看出他的担忧，或者也许其他人的担忧，但像这样慷慨的解读是，你知道，她有一个很酷的伙伴，她有一个玩偶，她和孩子们交谈，到目前为止对我来说似乎还可以。
Okay, fair enough, but keep in mind that walking around the park with the doll was just like the tip of the iceberg. Because apparently she would also host these dinner parties. And when everyone sat down for dinner, Nicholas would be seated at the table, like with his own spot and his own place setting and everything.
好吧，有道理，但请记住，带着玩偶在公园里走只是冰山一角。因为显然她还会举办这些晚宴。当每个人坐下来吃晚饭时，Nicholas会坐在桌子旁，就像有他自己的位置和自己的餐具等等。
And at like at a dinner party where you're supposed to talk to Nicholas, is that part of the deal? Yeah, I think so. And even Jan Pinbarrow, who of everyone I talked to for this story is probably the most ardent defender of Anchor Elmore, admitted that this could be a challenge for more friends and colleagues. It's been said that some people didn't like Nicholas because she did, I think, sometimes hide behind him.
在晚宴上，你必须和Nicholas交谈，这是交易的一部分吗？是的，我想是这样。甚至Jan Pinbarrow，在我为这个故事采访的所有人中，可能是Anne Carroll Moore最热心的捍卫者，也承认这对Moore的朋友和同事来说可能是一个挑战。据说有些人不喜欢Nicholas，因为她确实，我想，有时躲在他身后。
Like if she didn't want to give someone bad news, she might say, oh, Nicholas doesn't like that. You know, so I can imagine how that would grate on a person. Me too. Yeah, so, you mean, you can see where this is going, right? Because when Nicholas disapproved of something, whether it was like at a party or a work meeting, you were still expected to respond and apologize or whatever because this is Anne Carol Moore. Remember, she is this titan of children's books.
就像如果她不想给某人坏消息，她可能会说，哦，Nicholas不喜欢那样。你知道，所以我可以想象这会如何让一个人感到恼火。我也是。是的，所以，你的意思是，你可以看出这是怎么回事，对吧？因为当Nicholas不赞成某事时，无论是在聚会上还是在工作会议上，你仍然被期望做出回应和道歉等等，因为这是Anne Carroll Moore。记住，她是儿童读物的巨人。
And your career was in her hands. So you would just kind of be stuck talking to this doll. My hunch is that everyone talked about Nicholas Nickerbacher when Anne Carrollmore wasn't around. And when Anne Carrollmore was around, everyone was like, oh, hey, hi, Nicholas, how are you? You know, she wielded just a remarkable amount of power inside the library.
而你的职业生涯掌握在她手中。所以你只会有点被困在和这个玩偶交谈。我的直觉是，当Anne Carroll Moore不在时，每个人都在谈论Nicholas Nickerbacher。而当Anne Carroll Moore在场时，每个人都像，哦，嘿，嗨，Nicholas，你好吗？你知道，她在图书馆内拥有相当大的权力。
And so what would you do if you were in that situation and the person you depended on carrying around a wooden doll? You would be like, hey, Nicholas, good to see you. Have a seat at the table. Can I get you a cup of tea? And by some point, according to Jolapor, the whole conceit was taken so far that Nicholas actually had his own letterhead. And more would write letters to children's book authors and editors in the voice of the doll.
所以如果你处于那种情况，而你依赖的人带着一个木制玩偶，你会怎么做？你会说，嘿，Nicholas，很高兴见到你。在桌子旁坐下。我能给你倒杯茶吗？在某种程度上，根据Jolapor的说法，整个概念被推得太远了，以至于Nicholas实际上有他自己的信笺。而Moore会以玩偶的声音给儿童读物作者和编辑写信。
Oh my. And they would be signed Nicholas with a return address on the back of the envelope flap that said Nicholas Nickervacher and then the address of the central branch of the New York Public Library. So he lives at the library.. So he lives at the library. Right, he lives at the library. Comes the library. And the library.
哦，天哪。它们会被签名为Nicholas，信封盖背面有一个回信地址，上面写着Nicholas Nickerbacher，然后是纽约公共图书馆中央分馆的地址。所以他住在图书馆里。。所以他住在图书馆里。对，他住在图书馆里。来自图书馆。和图书馆。
Sure. Why not? That's when he writes his letters. Yeah. That's when he gets his best work done. Exactly. That is that is when he's at home. And so did the children's, you know, book editors and authors.
当然。为什么不呢？那就是他写信的时候。是的。那就是他完成最好工作的时候。确切地说。那就是他在家的时候。所以孩子们，你知道，书的编辑和作者们。
Did they write back to Nicholas? Was that like part of the deal of this fantasy? You know, I don't know. I do know that very frequently authors would send him their warm regards by way of Ankeral Moore. Like, please tell Nicholas, I say hello, because it was just understood that more and Nicholas were like a package deal. Yeah, that makes sense.
他们回信给Nicholas了吗？那是这个幻想交易的一部分吗？你知道，我不知道。我确实知道，作者们经常会通过Anne Carroll Moore向他致以热烈的问候。比如，请告诉Nicholas，我向他问好，因为大家都明白Moore和Nicholas就像一个捆绑销售。是的，这说得通。
But, you know, despite the creep factor, give a mind that like, you know, kids also wrote to Nicholas, right? Yeah. And some of the correspondence and gifts Nicholas received from adults also suggests that a lot of people saw Nicholas as this benign or even kind of benevolent presence. So, for example, the author of Billy Goat's Gruff made Ankerl more a miniature version of her first book for Nicholas to carry around.
但是，你知道，尽管有令人毛骨悚然的因素，请记住，孩子们也写信给Nicholas，对吧？是的。Nicholas从成年人那里收到的一些信件和礼物也表明，很多人认为Nicholas是一个良性的，甚至是仁慈的存在。例如，《三只公山羊格鲁夫》的作者为Nicholas制作了一个她第一本书的微型版本，让他随身携带。
Beatrix Potter sent her these little hand-drawn postcards depicting Peter Rabbit and Nicholas together, almost as if they were friends. And according to Jan, one of the employees from the library was like this Russian emigre. And she apparently gave Nicholas a Faberje egg. Whoa, like a real Faberje, like gemstones in it, type of Faberje egg.
Beatrix Potter寄给她这些手绘的小明信片，描绘了彼得兔和Nicholas在一起，几乎就像他们是朋友一样。根据Jan的说法，图书馆的一名员工就像是这位俄罗斯移民。她显然给了Nicholas一个法贝热彩蛋。哇，就像一个真正的法贝热，里面有宝石的那种法贝热彩蛋。
Yeah, well, she said there was a gem inside. So I can go with at least a, yes, a Faberje egg with one gem. But the point is that in the end, you can make an argument that Nicholas Nicarbocker's reign in the balance, you know, did more good than harm. And as was so much of what Anne Caramore did, it's, it's a close call. Well, I mean, creating a character to make kids comfortable in the library is
是的，好吧，她说里面有一颗宝石。所以我至少可以同意，是的，一个带有一颗宝石的法贝热彩蛋。但重点是，最终，你可以争辩说Nicholas Nickerbacher的统治，你知道，利大于弊。正如Anne Carroll Moore所做的大部分事情一样，这是一个艰难的决定。好吧，我的意思是，创造一个角色让孩子们在图书馆里感到舒适是
a totally nice and joyful thing to do. Making her employees, adult employees, talk to it is a little odd, but I hope it was good on balance. I mean, I hope for everyone's sake, it was good on balance. So Nicholas Nicobocker as an extension of Anne Carol Moore's personality. Did she just take it with her when she retired or did it sort of like live on in the libraries? It's like mascot. Excellent question, because this is where this whole weird side story kind of climaxes, which is when the elaborately rendered fiction of Nicholas collides with the reality. I'm good.
一件完全美好和快乐的事情。让她的员工，成年员工，和它交谈有点奇怪，但我希望它总体上是好的。我的意思是，我希望为了每个人的利益，它总体上是好的。那么Nicholas Nickerbacher作为Anne Carroll Moore个性的延伸。她退休时把它带走了，还是它像吉祥物一样在图书馆里活了下来？很好的问题，因为这就是整个奇怪的侧面故事达到高潮的地方，也就是Nicholas精心渲染的小说与现实碰撞的时候。我很好。
You know, he's just a doll. And dolls can be lost. Oh no. It was actually an employee of the library who was writing with Anne Carole Moore in a taxi cab and she was in charge of minding Nicholas and left it in the cab. Oh, I mean, I don't mean to disparage anyone's character, but I'm suspecting foul play here. I mean, if I was the indulged employee of Anne Carole Moore, and I was in charge of the doll, who I had to talk to and serve cookies to, I might be inclined to leave it in a cab too.
你知道，他只是一个玩偶。而玩偶是可以丢失的。哦，不。实际上是图书馆的一名员工，她和Anne Carroll Moore坐出租车，她负责照顾Nicholas，结果把它留在了出租车里。哦，我的意思是，我不是要诋毁任何人的品格，但我怀疑这里有猫腻。我的意思是，如果我是Anne Carroll Moore被宠坏的员工，而我负责照顾那个我必须交谈并提供饼干的玩偶，我也可能倾向于把它留在出租车里。
Yeah, you know, we'll never know. I'll give them the benefit of the doubt and say they're innocent, but I am sure many of more colleagues secretly cheered when this happened. But then a little while later, apparently more just went out and found a new little wooden Dutch boy. And basically said, like, oh, good news, everyone. Nicholas is back. Oh my goodness.
是的，你知道，我们永远不会知道。我会给他们无罪推定，说他们是无辜的，但我敢肯定，当这种情况发生时，许多Moore的同事都在暗中欢呼。但后来过了一会儿，显然Moore只是出去找了一个新的小木制荷兰男孩。基本上说，就像，哦，好消息，大家。Nicholas回来了。哦，天哪。
Oh, the rain of Nicholas keeps going. Yeah. And so much like Anne Carole Moore herself, Nicholas Nicarbocker, refused to retire. Oh, that's so good. Oh, that's so fascinating. I can totally see why that didn't belong in the story because I would be totally preoccupied with it. Today, Nicholas Nicobocker and many of the other figures in the story are getting to
哦，Nicholas的统治还在继续。是的。所以就像Anne Carroll Moore本人一样，Nicholas Nickerbacher拒绝退休。哦，那太好了。哦，那太迷人了。我完全明白为什么它不属于那个故事，因为我会完全被它占据。今天，Nicholas Nickerbacher和故事中的许多其他人物正在
live a strange afterlife thanks in part to this week's experts. Go to your local library and browse the children's section and you'll come across dueling picture books whose author's names, if you've been paying attention, will look familiar. Miss Moore thought otherwise how Anne-Karole Moore created libraries for children is written by Jan Pinbroe, and the important thing about Margaret Wise Brown is by Mac Barnett. Two books have two very different takes on what Anne-Karole Moore was really up to in our reading room. Whether she would have recommended either of them for purchase by expert, we will never
过着一种奇怪的来世，部分归功于本周的专家。去你当地的图书馆浏览儿童区，你会遇到两本对决的图画书，如果你一直在关注，作者的名字会看起来很熟悉。《Moore小姐另有想法：Anne Carroll Moore如何为儿童创建图书馆》由Jan Pinbroe撰写，《关于Margaret Wise Brown的重要事情》由Mac Barnett撰写。两本书对Anne Carroll Moore在我们的阅览室里到底在做什么有非常不同的看法。她是否会推荐专家购买其中任何一本，我们永远
know, but a good library and a good bookstore should carry them both. Thanks to all of our experts in today's story, if you're looking for a adult book on brown, check out Leonard Marcus' Margaret Wise Brown Awakened by the Moon. Thanks also to Settle Air, whose voice we did not get to include in this story, but whose book Children's Literature from Esaube to Harry Potter is a great guide to the deeper history of Kislet. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg with many assists from Vivian Le, original episode mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by Swan Rihale.
不知道，但一个好的图书馆和一家好的书店应该同时拥有它们。感谢今天故事中的所有专家，如果你正在寻找一本关于Brown的成人书，请查看Leonard Marcus的《Margaret Wise Brown：被月亮唤醒》。还要感谢Settle Air，我们没能把她的声音包括在这个故事中，但她的书《从伊索到哈利波特的儿童文学》是深入了解儿童文学历史的绝佳指南。99% Invisible本周由Joe Rosenberg制作，Vivian Le提供了许多帮助，原始剧集由Bryson Barnes混音，音乐由Swan Rihale创作。
Our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. Thresor team is Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzales, Christopher Johnson, Losh Medon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, and me Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of this Titcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now, headquartered in the Pandora Building within a mile of six public library branches, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
我们的高级编辑是Delaney Hall，Kurt Colstad是数字总监。我们的团队是Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzales, Christopher Johnson, Losh Medon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime，以及我Roman Mars。99% Invisible标志由Stefan Lawrence创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在，总部位于Pandora大楼，距离加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的六个公共图书馆分馆不到一英里。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，也可以在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上关注。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及99PI的每一集过往节目。你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。